[Musique]
ce sont mes camarades du collège
aujourd'hui on est mercredi la prof
d'histoire est absente alors je peux
rentrer chez moi
[Musique]
car que moi hercules et met un petit
coup de
[Musique]
mou
comment vous faites quoi
[Musique]
voilà
c'est quoi
une bouteille avec un parchemin à nantes
avoir
une carte aux trésors l'aide d'amis
et hop l'hydro de leur
larguer comme 3par
on n'est qu'à la fin on va par là
même si c'est un peu d'air at il avancé
[Musique]
bah on voit où un panneau et celui de
the hives ou les amis
[Musique]
tiens qu'est ce que c'est que ça
or on dirait une empreinte s'ennuyer
[Musique]
et attendez voir
ça vous fait penser à rien ah oui où
seul le surfeur sangliers d'éléments il
nous reste à trouver pas mal fini
ouvrez l'oeil les amis
en classe et sympa ce sentier littoral
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait
alors possible aventure
[Musique]
c'est le duo mais en est où
oh
regardez vos déchets via le tour au
dessus
oui on distingue deux semaines
[Musique]
comme c'était
même des sables
[Musique]
à
suis sûr que c'est par là oui on doit
plus être l on
[Musique]
pense que c'est par là on voit une case
d'abord
elle mais mangent dans la main
[Musique]
tu as dit oiseaux
ce
m
[Musique]
yes c'est à désespérer
pour ma ceinture
[Musique]
vous croire